hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about coupled transcription and
translation now I think that these are
processes you've probably heard of
before really quick let's just review
what they mean when the cell is
synthesizing in RNA as I'm called an
mRNA message from a DNA template this is
what happens in the process of
transcription when the mRNA synthesized
and transcription is then used as a
template for the synthesis of protein by
the cell this is what's happening in a
process of translation now these two
processes together are the major
processes of gene expression in the cell
when I made gene expression I mean the
information that is contained in this in
the gene in the genetic information in
this DNA of the cell it is being
expressed by way of an mRNA message that
has been translated during translation
to make protein and the proteins are the
functional units within the cell that
are carrying out the activities that are
encoded for by those genes and so these
processes transcription and translation
are the two major processes in gene
expression and we learn about them with
the central dogma and so if you're
interested in learning more about gene
expression and what it entails within
the central dogma you see my video on
that topic so now let's get back to this
idea of couples transcription and
translation and what that means now in
eukaryotes
remember that eukaryotes are all
organisms that are not prokaryotes so as
we mean by that there are differences
between eukaryotes and prokaryotes
oMG today the new carriers were mainly
thinking about animals including humans
also plants fungi algae things like that
and so in eukaryotes these two processes
transcription and translation are
separated both in time and in space and
what I mean by that is that eukaryotes
have a nuclear membrane that houses the
DNA so in all eukaryotic cells
transcription is happening where the DNA
is inside the nucleus translation is
happening in the cytoplasm outside the
nucleus and those transcription has to
complete first and then the completed
mRNA message actually gets a post
transcriptionally modified to make
what's called a mature mRNA transcript
if you're interested in learning more
about that post-transcriptional
modification process that occurs between
transcription and translation in
eukaryotes please see my video on that
topic and then once that mature
transcript has been completely modified
it then leaves the nucleus goes out into
the cytoplasm it's translated so in
eukaryotes transcription and translation
they have in a different places and
transcription happens first and then
translation happens second in
prokaryotes on the other hand which
includes all bacteria as well as a type
of cell called archaea so in prokaryotes
there is no nuclear membrane and so the
DNA is just free-floating in the
cytoplasm it is typically constrained to
a regular region of the cell but there's
still no nuclear membrane is completely
compartmentalizing and so there's no
nuclear membrane to separate these two
processes which means the transcription
and translation can actually be
occurring simultaneously and this is
what we say is coupling so the fact that
there's no nuclear membrane to separate
these two processes that is what allows
them to be coupled
couples just meaning that they are
occurring at the same time so now let's
look at what this looks like here in red
we have the DNA when it's being
transcribed the two strands of DNA
difficult part and an enzyme called RNA
polymerase that's here in blue there
right RNA halt for RNA polymerase it is
moving down the DNA creating mRNA here
this brown line coming off the RNA
polymerase is the mRNA and again this
red one up here is DNA so this mRNA is
being made by the RNA polymerase
remember that that is transcription so
this gene in the DNA is being
transcribed at the same time as the RNA
polymerase is sterile transcribing this
gene already you have ribosomes and the
ribosomes are here in orange each one is
an individual writers own from here I
have 1 2 3 4 5 6 drawn and that can be
many more so each individual ribosome is
already synthesizing proteins and that
is what is here shown in pink and this
is translations and this is a protein
and so you have all of these ping
polypeptides change ready for what make
up proteins and so as the other
ribosomes dots on the mRNA it starts
moving this way and as they get closer
and closer to where the RNA polymerase
is working they're making longer and
longer polypeptides now all of these
polypeptides are eventually going to be
the same protein because the the
ribosomes are translating the same gene
along this mRNA so here's a cell is
making many copies of the same protein
and you just see the size difference
here just one a singer simply because
this writer zone is further down the NRA
and so further along that process of
translation to say this one is for
example now when you come all of these
ribosomes working through side by side
although they are working independently
we actually call this right here a poly
ribosome or sometimes a poly film and
that is refers to the fact that there
are multiple ribosomes working at once
and just to reiterate they are
translating this protein translating the
mRNA into protein before this RNA
polymerase is even done transcribing of
course it does have to finish
transcribing before they can complete
their polypeptide synthesis but still
the processes are happening basically at
the same time and I want to point out
one more thing prokaryotic transcripts
tend to have many genes per transcript
not so the eukaryotes we usually only
have one gene on each mRNA transcripts
so prokaryotic transcript meaning the
mRNA can have many distinct unions on
them this is known as what is called up
polycistronic so polycistronic this
meaning that within one long mRNA
transcript there can be ribosomes that
are translating along different parts of
it resulting in different protein so
that is it today for couples
transcription and translation thank you
for watching